what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video today I will be
answering some of the questions you want
to know about this season and the
upcoming episodes of this season so
let's get started right away Targaryen
wolf said so do I understand this
correctly songs are one of John to
murder at least Karstark and Ned umber
to punish them and demonstrate to all
the northern Lords that treason is
treason
just like pycelle wanted sons are
murdered because of her father's
mistakes just like the way Joffrey was
publicly punishing Sansa because of
Rob's actions during the war the five
kings Songza wants to do the exact same
thing that he's kids right in my opinion
no she did not want to do the same
Sansa did not want the Karstark a number
of children murdered she only wanted
their castles and lands taken away from
them because their houses were fighting
for ramsay instead of John Sean's it did
want them punished but I do not believe
she wanted them killed League replays
asked do you think the night King might
have a connection with Jon Snow yes I
absolutely think the night King has a
connection with Jon Snow I think the
night King has a connection with all of
the Starks
I believe the night king is a stark not
only do I think he is a stark but I
believe he's another king of winter and
when the Starks say winter is coming
they don't only just mean that the
winter weather is coming but it also
means the king of winter is coming from
the lands of always winter and the king
of winter will need to be killed at
Winterfell because that's where winter
has fallen before that's why the night
king took such an interest in Jon Snow
at hardhome and that's why the night
king can share green dreams or visions
with brain stark because he is a stark
and he can probably sense them just like
the dire wolves have an internal sense
in connection with the other stark
children I think it's all connected and
we're gonna learn more about this before
it all ends jams Bam's asked do you
think Theon will fully redeem himself or
could he end up dying or both
yes I believe Theon will fully redeem
himself
I think Theon might end up killing his
uncle euron greyjoy Theon's uncle Euron
wants to kill him in his sister and he's
not going to stop until he has an
opportunity to do this and as of right
now it doesn't look like Theon would
stand a chance against his uncle but I
kind of think that's why
makes the most sense for Theon to be the
one to stop him but if Theon doesn't
kill you're on then I think Jaime
Lannister will kill you're on and if
that's the case then I think Phelan will
redeem himself by sacrificing himself
for one of the Starks just like he was
going to do for sawn zone when Theon and
Sansa was hiding from Ramsay's hounds
Theon told Songza to stay hidden and
Filan stepped out in front of the men to
give himself up so songs that could
escape that could have been the end of
Theon's Redemption arc right there but
it wasn't
Theon is still heavily involved in the
plot for a reason Theon is back in the
heart of Westeros with Daenerys
Targaryen and before it's all said and
done he's going to do something
courageous even if it means sacrificing
his own life he may have a few more
cowardly moments till but he will step
up to the plate when he is needed the
most how stark the North remembers asked
do you think we get both battles of
Casterly Rock the sacking of Highgarden
and the field of fire 2.0 in episode 2
no we are not going to see the field of
fire 2.0 until episode 4 or 5 the field
of fire battle will be with the Dothraki
and at least one of the nearest
Targaryens dragons and the director who
filmed these scenes was Matt Shaikh Minh
in the episodes he was scheduled to film
or episode 4 & 5 Bob wants to know what
happened to Ed Meera Tolly after the
blackfish was taken down Jaime and Bronn
went back to the twins to celebrate and
water Frey told Jaime Lannister that he
had ed mirror put back in the cells
Walder Frey said he couldn't kill ed
mirror because it would give the family
a bad name and I was kind of hoping Arya
was gonna free ed mirror but since they
didn't show us that I can only assume he
has been written out of the show for now
if Arya didn't free him from the cells
then that's where he should still be G
ot and BTS high-class trash said this is
kind of a weird question but I'm just
curious I want to know your opinion do
you think there was a chance that Cersei
and Jaime will die together something
like we were born together and we will
die together yes I think there is a very
high chance they died together and you
said it yourself they were born together
so they could die together in the
television show Jaime may be the one to
kill Cersei and if he does he may want
to die in the arms of the woman he loves
just like he said he wanted to do but I
have a feeling there's gonna come a time
Jaime won't love her at all anymore
in Bryan could be the woman he loves
whose arms he dies in I would prefer if
Jamie would survive and help out during
the war for the dawn but there is
definitely a chance they died together a
very high chance in my opinion Stephen
said a bit of a noob question I get that
John stressed that dragonglass is needed
for making weapons out of them for
everyone including woman and children to
fight the white walkers but there are so
many more whites to fight than white
walkers so do the dragon class weapons
apply to fighting the whites as well as
the white walkers or can whites be
stopped with non-conventional weapons
that aren't made of dragonglass given
how widely the whites fought at hardhome
I can't see how any weapons made of
dragonglass or not wielded by women and
children is gonna stop these whites all
right let's start back at the top
dragonglass weapons do not kill whites
they only kill white walkers there is a
big difference between it too the whites
need to be killed what fire that's the
only way you can completely stop the
whites even if you chop the whites up
into pieces they can still kill you you
got to use fire and only fire the reason
why John is so concerned with getting
dragonglass is because the white walkers
are very hard to kill the white walkers
have superhuman strength and they are
amazing fighters now I know there might
be more whites but there could
potentially be over 90 white walkers out
there and only having a few Valyrian
swords isn't enough Craster gave 99 of
his sons to the night king and we have
only seen a couple of them killed Sam
killed one John killed one and Meera
killed one the most white walkers we
have ever seen at one time was 14 when
the night King turned the baby into a
white Walker there was 12 white Walker
standing in the back plus the night king
and plus the baby so there is 14 in that
scene alone and since Craster gave up
ninety nine of his sons we could see a
hell of a lot more if Jon can get enough
dragonglass for everyone the chances of
killing the night King are a lot higher
and if you can stop the night king then
you can stop the whites the night King
is warding all of these whites and if
you kill the night King and shut off his
brain
all of the whites will probably
deactivate and drop dead again Jon wants
to stop the Creator the animator Jon
probably doesn't know how many White
Walkers there are too for all he knows
there could be thousands of them you got
to remember Jon knows nothing
and I apologize to this next person
because I cannot read your name but this
person asked what is the name of aurea's
direwolf
the answer is named area next question
I'd asked since in the first episode
John said he wants every man woman and
child from ten to sixty training to
fight does this mean saw ins a - do you
think we will ever see her with Arya
trained in the future
that's a good question I'm assuming when
John said that he did mean everyone and
it's kind of hard to picture songs of
fighting someone with a sword but when
the night King comes everyone better
have a weapon in their hand it wouldn't
be right to sit on your ass while
everyone else is doing all the work
John was pretty serious when he said
everyone needs to fight Arya could
definitely help Songza but Songza
already has a great swordsman right by
her side
Shawn's that could have Brienne train
with her and get her ready but I do not
think we're gonna see songs of train in
the show though I'd be pretty surprised
if they spent time showing that if
Shawn's is gonna pick up a sword anytime
soon it better be used to kill
Littlefinger Juelz question is do you
think Cersei will actually marry your on
when he returns with her gifts if so do
you think your own will kill Cersei on
their wedding night I don't think
they're actually gonna get married but I
wouldn't be surprised if they did get
married but I doubt it but I do think
there is a chance he might kill her the
type of person you're on is he is
capable of killing anyone and some of
the book text points to this so I give
it a 50/50 chance with both of those
questions if Cersei is very happy with
his gifts and the mountain lets him get
close enough they could start a physical
relationship and then get married or
this could get him close enough to kill
her I could see either one but I
wouldn't bet money on it
Tyler asked do you think John will learn
about his parentage next episode no I
don't think so they're most likely going
to continue to tease this for a while
some other people in the show might find
out this season but I don't think John's
gonna find out until season 8 John is
gonna leave Winterfell next episode and
he might not be back until next season
he has a lot of traveling to do in the
next six episodes the jawless question
is do you think there is any possibility
that at the end of it all John and the
Dragon Queen will get the world of Seven
Kingdoms together no I don't really
think so that sounds like too much of a
happy ending and I don't think there's
going to be
happy ending when it's over at least
George said there wouldn't be George
said it would be a bittersweet ending
now Dana and Dave might want to do what
they want but I think one of them will
die in the end and maybe even both of
them die in the end I think we're gonna
lose almost all of the cast members in
season 8 when the final war is over but
that's just my opinion Neil asked do you
think we're gonna see Hodor marching in
the army of the Dead I really don't know
now when I saw those three giants
marching with the dead I honestly
thought to myself we could see just
about anything reanimated now Hodor
summer ice spiders polar bears we might
see all kinds of [ __ ] but I would be
surprised if we did see Hodor
but I'm not going to count anything out
now are gim beö to ask when will bran
show up I think we're gonna see bran in
the next episode Jamie will be leaving
for Highgarden very soon and bran it's
gonna go with him I think we're gonna
see bran in either episode 2 or 3 for
sure
Sherlock's [ __ ] wants to know how Sam
will cure Joris greyscale it looks like
Sam might use some dragon glass to cure
it dragon glass might not be the only
thing he uses but dragon glass will
probably be needed to cure him somehow
one of the books and was reading
mentioned dragon glass and cure on the
same page so it's probably going to be
in that direction Miss Piggy asked where
is Gendry
I think injury went back to King's
Landing to be honest with you after
Davos set him free he probably went back
to being a blacksmith it's the only
thing he really knows how to do and the
man's got to eat I think he's been in
King's Landing smithing for someone else
this entire time bongo drums said how
big do you think knime areas wolf pack
is they ain't limited by CGI so
hopefully huge that's a pretty good
question I'm gonna say around a dozen at
the most it would be awesome if there
was over a hundred in the pack but my
guess would be about 10 to 12 or less
cat asked which of the same snakes do
you think will die and how do you think
it might happen I am curious in my
opinion I think all of them are gonna
die Joran is going to kill some of them
out on the sea and then the mountain is
gonna kill the rest I know some people
want to see bran and tyene live happily
ever after but I don't think that's
gonna happen I think Dorne is done well
I think this is a good spot to end the
video that was about 20
students on this one I want to thank all
of you for leaving your comments on my
last video I really appreciate that and
I also want to thank all of you for
watching today's video and my supporters
on patreon I hope you all have a good
day and I'll see you down below bye